the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so as you might have noticed more much
of this class and much of our work in a
sense is about designing good policies
given the particular challenge and
environment the policy is functioning in
so that's a lot lot of what we do if you
look at a lot of how policy is made in
the world it has less to do with the
problem then we to do with other
priorities so the example we give in the
book and his emphasize here is Egypt
Egypt was became a major recipient of US
aid in 1979 when Egypt essentially broke
ranks with the Arab countries and signed
the Camp David Accord with Israel and
the Camp David Accord was not quite a
declaration of friendship but it was
enough of a enough of a change in the
relationship that the that the that the
Egypt was then on seen as the as a major
ally for us Israeli interests in the
Middle East so it was a it was a very
substantial political change as a reward
in a sense for agreeing to that Egypt
was offered a lot of aid every year so
Egypt is the biggest recipient other
than Israel off of US aid over this
period and that was not based on the
idea that either that Egypt was a
country that was particularly poor he's
if it is none the richer countries in
Africa or on the idea that Egypt was
going to do a lot of good with the money
no such presumption open such idea what
they were mooted it was very clear that
the easy the money in Egypt was supposed
to be a payoff for being friendly a pair
of not necessarily to the president but
a payoff to you know maybe to some
extent to the military establishment in
Egypt so a payoff nonetheless so it was
very much seen as a payoff so that was
as a result when basically if you take
the amount enough aid was given to egypt
every year to pay twenty dollars per
african child under five so just to get
a magnitude of that Egypt is not the
richest countries in Africa the aid
given to Egypt was so large that it
could have been given if it was given to
the rest of africa you read five dollars
for every child under five so that's a
significant amount of money it was not
given based on the idea that Egypt was
going to make very good use of this
money since there was certainly no it
was not really development aid it was
just it as a price for being our friends
and that's an important example because
it underscores the point that even
though even though we may work very hard
and come up with policies that make
sense often money is spent for reasons
which have nothing to do with sense or
may have sense but sense in some other
calculus
so if if that's what you're going to do
and thats related to a separate point
which is so one point you my that comes
up in that process is that you know
what's the point of knowing anything if
money is going to be not given if bunny
will not be given where the information
is the information says that you should
do this policy but in fact Egypt gets
all the money because it happens to be
the country that's willing to be nice to
Israel so that's a one question related
question is you know some countries just
don't have a functioning state right now
prominent example is Cote d'Ivoire but
the or if you noticed has an ongoing
civil war where the president is
supposed to have lost the election but
doesn't seem to want to leave and
there's an French army in there and
which which may or may not succeed in
reestablishing order etc so at this
point you know who's going to do we
might discover the very efficient way to
find people get people to immunize their
children but you know that might be
beside the point in for the volumes in
its true this because they were right
now there is no state and therefore you
know if you think of a policy that is
going to be adopted by the state who's
going to be the state that adopts that
so that's sort of the big so a lot of
people have made that point against us
if you like and I think the most
articulate version of that is this this
this paragraph by Bill easterly who says
randomized control trials are infeasible
for many of the big questions of
development like the economy why these
two effects of good institutions or good
macroeconomic policies embracing
randomized control trials has led
development researchers to lower their
missions
so this is the basically this is not the
you know the big issues are not being
touched here what we are doing is we are
solving a small problem and because and
since and the implied argument is that
if you don't solve the small big
problems there's no reason to sum all
those solve the small ones we should
start by solving the big problems of
state formation of good macroeconomic
policy is getting an effective
functioning state and then solve the
other problems so there's a lot of
people a lot of people who are I think
very fine economists who believe in this
position which is what I would call the
institutional list view and that's
really too sir two separate if possibly
independent claims one is it without
good politics you cannot have good
policies and the second is that with
good politics good policies will follow
so they're their claims in two
directions right it's one is going from
one is a positive claim there is a
negative claim that is hopeless to try
to do anything if you have bad politics
and and what here what what people
really mean by politics is not just that
you know you should have to a good
leader or something but you need a whole
a package of the water what people think
of as appropriate institutions so the
basic vision is that there are
appropriate institutions and your things
like property rights what basically is
their private property or not is private
property well secured that's one one
thing people focus on the second thing
people focus on is is whether whether
the political system is relatively open
the design constraints on the executive
or whether the
basically absolutism so the guy who's
running in power can do whatever he
wants so so those are the kinds of
things so we will use though I'm going
to keep using institutions with capitals
for a while and you see why later so I'm
going to use it in capital for the time
being so these the well let me say what
I am trying to get at these are not only
institutions mit is an institution to
but it's not institution in the same
sense as property rights is an
institution right it might easily I mean
I'm sure MIT is a veritable respected
institution but it would not count in
the same sensors institutions in this in
this sense this is institutions meaning
meaning these big things that define how
the economic and political system
jointly functions there are a few
institutional a few kind of structural
features of the economy which drive
everything else and those are things
like property rights political system
etc so i think one interesting place to
start is to look at the work of SFO glue
Johnson and Robinson arsenal Louanne
Johnson are both MIT professors this is
a really interesting book and what I'm
trying to going to try to what they
claim in their book is that countries
succeed or fail based on based on
institutions as defined by property
rights few things like prop of this
nature of property rights and nature of
the political system etc and and what
they have done I think very compellingly
is provides some very interesting
evidence along this line so I'm going to
start by presenting the evidence and
then we'll think about what the wall
what in given that every
how should we think about the world now
the first reason why this evidence is
difficult is because institutions are
endogenous what do I mean by NSA
institutions are endogenous
so using chocolate
are not perfect by local conditions
but they fall by something that's tricky
so why so you add to that
but so you might say that for example
you to have effective property rights we
need effective courts to effective to
have effective courts we need effective
judges to have effective judges we need
an effective education system to have an
effective education system we might need
good property rights so in might all of
these things are related and we may you
know if people my education system best
in the education system may not be
effective with our property right so all
of these things are related so basically
institutions are endogenous in this
sense that lots of things that other
matter for other aspects of the economy
also affect institutions institutions
are a result of what what else is
happening in the economy there are also
calls so that's what makes it difficult
so how do you study the effects problem
with things we are endogenous is that
how do you study the effects of those
because in some sense the basic rule of
our study the effect of something is
what you want to do is you want to say
here's two countries one country has
better institutions than the other
entirely by chance not because this
country has some other aspects that
makes it better right we want to the
problem is we worried that you know if I
say that Spain has better in for info
institutions then Portugal then I would
need to argue that that this is not a
result of the fact that Spain was to
start with a stronger economy and that's
why the institutions came out we want to
say there are two countries which
essentially identical and by an act of
chance Portugal got worse institutions
and Spain and those acts of chance are
difficult to find that's basically the
challenge so how does anybody solve this
problem well here's a very nice insight
the very nice insight is
that in former colonies to take the
countries that were European colonies
with a lot of countries pretty much all
of Africa and most of Asia and most of
Latin America all of Latin America most
of Asia and most of Africa were former
colonies of either Britain France
Holland Portugal Spain or Belgium
essentially these six countries were
between them in Germany to a very small
extent had most of the world carved up
so most countries were colonies of these
countries and it it turns out not
surprisingly it's what what was said a
little while ago institutions of
persistent so if institutions we're good
institutions were set up in this country
a long time ago they still remain
relatively good and bad institutions
were set up so good and bad here are I'm
not telling you what good and bad dad
yet I'll tell you what they mean in a
minute but the basic theory is that
whatever whatever institutions were set
up a long time ago that's how they stay
so institutions are persistent a step 1
sep step two is to observe that when
Europeans settled in a country they were
very clear about what kinds of
institutions they want to set up and
that has a lot to do with whether they
want to live in the country or not if
they didn't want to live in the country
so they just wanted to go there control
the country and you know make some money
from it then this institutions they set
up enabled making money quickly in the
country so they were not very protective
of the local population they were what
are called extractive institutions
institutions which basically take the
shape of you know it's easy to easy easy
to easy to kind of bully people not not
a lot of legal protection so that you
could you could extract whatever you
wanted you want the minds to be very
profitable you don't really want legal
rights for the workers because if you
had legal rights for the workers then
they would complain and then you
wouldn't get very profitable mines so if
you want mine to be profitable the best
way to do it is to not have very many
legal rights for workers if you want
labor to be cheap you don't educate the
labor force if you want people to be
people to be docile you you don't want
to have a lot of democracy so basically
if you on the other hand if you you
Europeans were going to stay there then
the vision for the country was very
different they wanted it to be livable
and unlike their lives in Europe and
then they set up institutions which were
much less directly extractive and that's
that happens to be true sadly enough so
what are countries where Europeans did
settle and where what are countries
where they didn't settle examples
what are countries where they didn't
settle and you can start to see what the
pattern is going to be what account is
where they didn't settle yeah sorry
when we ever get injured cycle South
Africa to some extent is a pathway some
extent kami those were three countries
where they settled and most other
countries they didn't settle so that's a
that's an example of you can see that
now one reason so here's what's nice
about the paper they claim that one
reason this happened was because of
settler mortality so if you look at the
moment if you if you look at the these
early colonies in the year first years
of settlement then massive mortality
rates really massive like five or four
out of five people died within five
years that kind of mortality rates
because Europeans were encountering new
diseases basically new tropical diseases
of all kinds so the mortality rates were
massive and so therefore the places
where they agreed to settle were places
where they the way when the mortality
rates were relatively low and so one
good predictor of what happens say
whether you get whether you get whether
you get one good predictor of whether
you get a European settlement or not is
settler mortality in the early days and
so on what they did it is very creative
is to find a data set of settler
mortality in this place and that's a
that's a so basically the idea is let's
look at what happens let's compare
places where the settlers died in droves
with places where they didn't
so here's a set of pictures that
underline that underpin their papers so
let's start with the first one this is
really this Ben this is the picture of
you know GDP per capita on on
expropriation risk exploration risk is
how secure are property so expropriation
is the opposite of property rights so
expectation risk is just you know how
likely is it that if you have a private
property it'll be just be taken away by
the state so that's and you see that
countries were it varies a lot it's high
in in Haiti Haiti in Mali in nazare
Nigeria is low in the US Singapore
Australia and New Zealand so if you look
at the colonies that do well they tend
to be they tend to be relatively the
richer colonies are also the ones which
had lower expectation risk so now this
is this is the endogenous regression
because you could have almost run this
regression the other way round you could
have asked is it the case that rich
countries have have lower expropriation
risk this is not a regression that can
be causally interpreted by itself
because it's it's exactly saying that
you know expropriation risk is high in
rich countries but is that because rich
rich countries are safer or is it
because safe countries are richer we
don't know okay so this this pictures
now before I come to lecture let me skip
skip these two pictures come back to
them later here is a more maybe
revealing picture this picture says
what's the relationship between settler
mortality and GDP per capita this is
kind of a dramatic fact which is that if
settler mortality was high like in The
Gambia gmb Nigeria Molly Togo those
countries of poor countries which are
which are rich tended to have had low
settler mortality so we think that
settler mortality has nothing to do with
GDP today then that's a surprising fact
you why was it that settlers when they
came to settle when did they come to
suddenly in the Americas one way the
Americas settled sixteenth and
seventeenth century when was Africa's at
all 19th century so these are all a long
time when was a sheís Apple when did
Asia one was Asia conquered
18th and 19th mostly so some so these
are all everything that we are talking
about is saying that what happened
before 1850 or eighteen eighty basically
has a strong consequence of what's on
outcomes today so if you were a country
where Europeans died in droves in 1870
like Gambia or 18 I know whenever there
was eighteen sixty people drive it died
in droves in eighteen sixty then gambia
still a poorer country so that's sort of
an interesting correlation and here's
the here's why they think that this now
they're stored they are then asked a
question now that I told you that
Gambia's poorer than the US and it used
to and even 120 years ago I could have
predicted this you say why why would
that be the case how could you what the
link between 120 years and now and their
claim is that this is the persistence of
institution so gambia is a place where
the Europeans didn't settle as a result
they set up extractive institutions and
extractive institutions are very
persistent so the reason why we see this
mapping from settler mortality to
expropriate in risk to GDP is the reason
why we have the persistence with settler
mortality affected institutions when the
country was set up which affected
institutions now and it's very dramatic
again the quality of the institutions
goes down very fast which sets of
mortality
so that's the basic argument basic
argument of paper is these two facts
which is that look G countries we said
hi circle of mortality a poorer and they
had they have poorer institutions and so
and there's no reason why something that
happened so long ago would affect
outcomes today and therefore it must be
institutions now they do something else
that's actually very interesting in fact
they do more than this what I told you
is they actually one thing they do is to
argue that in the world of life they say
19 1500 or 1600 we don't know GDP in
1600 so what they're going to try to
argue is not just that we see this
pattern but this pattern reflects
doesn't reflect fix geographical
characteristics of these countries
because you have a fixed geographers
characteristics of this country's then
the countries where they you had had low
settler mortality would have been
countries which were richer already in
1500 so it's not the case that so one
thing they want to show is that this is
not the effect of some long-term
historical difference it is not that the
countries that have low settler
mortality we're rich countries already
so the US which had lost cetera
mortality was actually a poor country in
1500 how do they show that but they
can't actually measure GDP in 1500 very
well but one thing they can do is they
can use urbanization rates or population
density historically richer countries
had more population so let's start with
this
no start with this picture this picture
says that you look at arbonne ization
and jay DB per capita these are
extremely correlated right extremely
tightly related so then they are making
the point that therefore urbanization
rates today in 1500 are a reasonable
proxy for gdp in 1500 that's the second
step in the argument and and you don't
so this picture says urbanization rates
in GD in 1500 if you assume that's a
predictor of gdp in 1500 and look at
that relationship what does that say
what do
yeah richest country within 1500 support
this sound sorry I wouldn't population
density played a huge role so areas
you're looking at fertilization Rangers
you compare the alcohol
guys do your
where
alright those are both good points hold
them or come back to them okay they're
asking questions or whether this is this
album is you're trying to pick holes in
this argument let's wait on that I want
to understand the argument before
created picking holes in it so I think
both points you made our are interesting
will hold them will repeat them in a
minute so right now they're making the
case look it's not not that there is a
persistence of poverty it is not the
case that the countries that were poor
in 1504 poor now if organization is a
good measure of poverty then of being
wealthy then those countries were rich
countries then poor countries now and
the US for example was a poor country
than in a rich country now indeed
famously there's a claim that the reason
why the British didn't manage to take
back the u.s. in 1776 because I mean the
US was very weak relative to the Britain
in 1776 how did it how did the u.s.
colin is managed well there was a threat
of another attack to the two I think to
Jamaica which was a much wealthier area
sugar growing much wealthy area so
that's why the British government had to
decide whether to protect Jamaica to
protect the US and he decided Jamaica
was more worth protecting than the u.s.
may have not been the rest right
judgment historically but nonetheless so
they made this call on it based
apparently on the fact that Jim Jamaica
was a wealthier area this is another one
this is unlock population density which
is another classical measure of wealth
so typically historically more populated
countries are rich have been richer
countries indeed historically a lot of
people said that you know you know
basically the there was people often
suggested a very simple model
which is sometimes called the Malthusian
model which is that if countries are
more productive they can sustain a
bigger population because if if not if
you if you are not promote productive
then if you had a bigger population the
staff to death so basically the
Malthusian model says that more
productive countries had bigger
populations and you see that if you
believe that then once again richer
countries in 1500 are poorer countries
now finally population density in 1500
is you can see is a negative predictor
of expropriation risk now so more dense
countries in 1500 have have worse
protection against expropriation so they
have lost property rights and you
basically this what this is saying is
that you look at the economic outcomes
of the high urbanization countries in
the lower organization countries in in
1500 you can see that the higher res
Asian countries actually fall below the
lower precision countries the middle of
the 18th century in the middle of the
19th century this is GDP so they call
this the reversal of fortune so 22
claims being made one is that there was
that rich countries became poorer and
the reason why they became poorer is
because of the pattern of settlement we
generated better institutions which
generated better economic outcomes
okay then they go on to claim that is I
had the same institutions of the u.s.
today 35 tears richer so that was that's
a that's the is a huge claim right it's
huge the magnet languages they're
talking about an immense so you are you
are beginning to so now coming back to
the question you are trying to starting
to ask questions about this evidence
what are possible ways in which this
evidence might be misleading so good
let's go back to you
compare tropical countries before there
were long lines to your country
actually well as the other countries
institutions have population
part of the reasons that
so you say empty places may be different
with bases were empty they might be
development patterns may be different
from variety of reasons which may not
have to do with with institutions it may
well be that if you start with an empty
place you can have a am or a different
development pattern even if you have the
same institutions that's one of the is
that what you say
our population is to start off that
stage there your attitude is why would I
why would why would that make sense
better investment because because in
comparing sort of Latin America
sub-saharan Africa vapor swamps travel
there already were sort of bridge
cultures driving there and that
hearing those
those places to say North American
Indian
population
here at would have been a lot more
prosperous compare it to you say that
this that may may be comparing with the
with the places where the empty places
what is is misleading because those
places are but it still isn't the point
that this misleading because empty
places would for some reason would have
a different development path after all
the empty process cross the bed become
better so you're saying that even
without good institutions empty places
who might have had a different path
because maybe it is the case that the
population just the population
composition is different if I settle if
there's no one else living there and I
go and settle I'm hundred percent of the
population and whereas if a lot of
people living there then if I go settle
I'm a different fraction of the
population okay you were the countries
that actually polarize you know the ones
who
I should go and settle feeling the
venerable country because that basic
difference on however Tony does I crazy
bollock only is that ended up doing well
word you know fridge cons and of course
the univ india which you know there's
not a thing cuz that no dead well
nigeria Donna Uganda but Sierra Leone
lots of British colonies barma those
seven of different times right like the
like the many of the I mean a lot of
like
exploration of course goes already
trafficking tips of slavery things like
that digging into sixteen hundred or so
but you know a lot of the colonies to
have a word you know in a different time
history spectrum so I just think that
you know the big market was just
different like the world was very
different at the time yeah but I didn't
see how why Jetson the point explain I
think I live with everything you said
I'd oops you want to add to that I don't
understand exactly why that's a
criticism what they're doing I
understood if you said
okay that's absolutely true I think
everything you said is true but I don't
see why so they were definitely column
eyes in different times but still two
things they they do one is a compared
with in Africa they can compare with in
Africa is not quite statistically as
solid as it should be but you can still
do it you can compare zire non-solid
zimbabwe south africa kenya with the
rest of africa the country's of high
settlement low settlement and you see
some of the same difference mostly
driven by South Africa unfortunately
which is rather special but you do so
you can do it the second thing you can
do is you can control for the identity
the colonizer and that doesn't change
anything so you can compare only British
colonies with British colonies and that
that doesn't change anything that's much
more solid so you could compare just
French colonies with French colonies
British colors with British colonies and
average but I really you can do that
that becomes two smaller data set so if
you compare only Spanish colonies within
Africa there will be two and that may
not be that's not going to be a lot of
bridge for
probably better off than let's say four
cheese colonies regularly true where
it's gonna compare that to South Africa
South Africa's much much better probably
true but I that's not what they do I
mean they worried about that comparison
is difficult because British colonies
are not randomly chosen Britain was one
of the leaders in African colonization
Britain was one of the leaders Britain
got all the most productive countries so
we look look at France didn't was a
follower and so France ended up with the
less productive countries so Britain
targeted some countries and he grabbed
the best ones like so this is not an
accident yeah
for there
institutions and if some stew
manas that's a good point but that's
that that they won't disagree with of
this really they're just saying imagine
that they said that you know places
which had no one there or very low
population density in the beginning it
was easier to set up fresh institutions
and fresh institution persist would you
say that that's not a version of the
institutionalist argument that's just a
slight variant on there i would I don't
think is that different
but that's absolutely true they would
say that that's still around 14 why
expropriating institutions are bad you
are just making a slightly different
room for IX expropriating institutions
are bad yeah yeah just just getting back
to the point in a little but so when you
say yeah that's correct but you know the
very point was sort of the leader
critical eyes in Africa however that's
not the case when you're talking about
Americans right and I am right so like
here though Spain Portugal leaders in
this case you know it's not like they
dating radicalization and when you even
like reference the paper in British
Empire shows the richer countries in
Annapolis what does that imply that they
would have a position that's more
exploration base in there for maybe you
know some that would be worse position
por eso does that make sense or is it
isn't really it's not so clear they like
him this is we're getting off point
let's sis just just to comment that the
British might have picked better places
and better places may be more productive
they might also be more attractive to be
expropriating but those two factors are
going opposite direction so you might if
you started with better places that
already helps you a lot and maybe then
you exploit a bit more you set up
slavery or something or but still it
might well be on balance that you do
less damage there it's not clear because
you know you start with a better place
then you do a little more damage I don't
know which way it goes but you right
when we that's that that's a certainly a
good point any other concerns
this is terrible
well to be honest I think if you look at
the world in 1800 the United States
doesn't look like a more valuable
economy it looks like a less valuable
economy because the idea was that places
that could grow sugar were the most
valuable places so when you compare when
they compared places within America's
they typically compare Jamaica with the
US and Jamaica was the place which
looked more valuable than us was a good
actually a good place to settle because
no one was empty and no one wanted to
come there so it was empty and no not
much competition Jamaica was the British
were very worried that the Spanish would
take Jamaica yeah
North America
for Asia
it's left there
that is a DS shap
but that's that's the point about the
reversal of fortune in a sense the
reversal of fortune is exactly the point
that these were richer places in in in
1500 the places which are poor now we're
rich places so somehow you need to argue
the geography has a different effect
then than it has now it's not
implausible so you might do one one
point that I think uu KU one point you
could make is that geography is not some
fixed thing these countries were poorer
richer then because this was a period
when it turned out that agriculture
mattered and then they invested a lot of
lot in agriculture turned out that by
some accident industry became the big
thing later and so places that started
later more were more able to jump onto
the industry man wagon then the place is
that so jog raphy might be a geography
that helped you originally might hurt
you later because you are you know
Jamaica specialized in sugar sugar was
great in 1800 but not so great now
because you know something better or
discovered so maybe what happened was
that these places that were it was not
the institutions it was just the
specialization in certain products that
that really mattered you will continue
just like today
but why why but in some sense why is it
that way to find you you but isn't that
just a version of the institutional
institutional argument that you know
where you want to extract diamonds you
don't create any institutions you just
extract and that's exactly their point
in a sense is that you create extractive
institutions that doesn't seem any
different from just seems like a variant
on they are woman that you know where
you set up extractive institutions you
get bad outcomes yeah so could it be the
case so she's Irish a competitive edge
if as they had invested a lot in
agriculture night
and they were but as times change never
comes
it also be the case that the other
countries with the ones in temperate
environments were forced to look at
other things earlier because the
agriculture wasn't there a very real
advantage and that was a bet they may
not know how the future would be
excellent that's an excellent point so
it could be that just you know if you
have very easy access to very productive
agriculture when you create a society
which is not looking forward to solving
certain types of problems so that's an
excellent point I don't know it's true
or not but is an ex extremely
interesting observation and thought of
that and more generally I mean one
concern with this kind of evidence is
that you know as you might imagine there
are not that many when the most
compelling examples turn out to be Hong
Kong Singapore South Africa l+ US Canada
New Zealand Australia if you know really
a very few they're really the
regressions driven by very few countries
though I think if you look at this
picture it's less true that I you might
imagine so look at this is actually no
let's yeah we can do this one so you
look at this picture it's not entirely
driven by so if you look at that square
in the middle even there there's a
slight downward slope so leave out us
New Zealand Canada Singapore Hong Kong
Malaysia those are on the left and just
south africa and whatever one other
country don't know what it is and look
at the block in the middle where India
is the top left-hand point and whatever
BML I is molly is the bottom left point
a bottom right point even within the
square this clear downward slope I think
so it is not you can leave out even if
you left out the very rich countries you
do get a weaker but significant
relationship and that still tells you if
you just took that relationship you
still will get a big effect of off
settler mortality even if you left out
the very you know if you really
exceptionally rich countries or
something you still get reasonably good
good fit I guess one concern I have is
whether or not expropriation risk is
something that we assign two countries
based on success so one worry I have is
that it may well be that the that the
countries that had high settler
mortality are poor for whatever reason
and then we think it's because of
expropriation risk with expectation risk
is just based on here you know our
perception of economic success so India
and Pakistan are very a very design very
different expectation risk one is at
eight and there's at six I'm not sure
that those are based on anything
particular I think there might well be a
legitimation of success so countries
which are successful are assigned better
these numbers who knows what expiration
risk is it's some some number somebody
made up and we may worry that this
number isn't quite isn't quite right and
maybe all it does it is just reflects
the fact that richer countries are
richer so you know people assign them
higher you know these countries are
richer they must have good property
rights I don't know how much of that's
what's going on so but I still think
that in some sense I I guess i'm more
more inclined to to take this every day
as telling us something interesting but
I have to but I think one should take it
really seriously so first point it's
making if you take it seriously is not
that the institutions are important it's
not saying just that institutions are
important it's saying something much
more specific than that it's an
institution that will set up a long time
ago and evolve slowly over time in
countries where where there was low
settler mortality are very different
from institutions that were set up a
long time ago and evolve for a long time
in high settler mortality countries so
it's not saying that if I suddenly took
Molly and give it the institutions of
the u.s. the institutions will
automatically start functioning that's
not in this data is not saying anything
about whether or not we can replace
institutions in one place by the other
right it's in fact saying quite the
opposite saying saying that you know all
we can tell is that Institute places
that got goodies traditions because of a
lucky accident 200 years over 400 years
ago are better off now that's not
necessarily a big policy in policy
health policy so that it says that we
could change institutions today
successfully that's not what it implies
it could be true that we can change it
but this is not what we learned from
this evidence what we learn who these
evidence is if we happen to have been
lucky four hundred years ago then we are
lucky today but that's a that's a very
different point from saying that we are
able to fix institutions today and if we
make give Molly the same institutions of
the US had unless that's I'm not not
just making a debating point think about
what the US Constitution means the US
Constitution means a lot of things but
it it also means the culture you know
every person who goes to school in the
US learns about the Constitution it
creates a certain set of loyalties to
the Constitution we are very important
it is emphasized that this
the long history there are lots of
battles about this quarry the
Constitution in the Supreme Court and
other court all of these things are part
of the effectiveness of the Constitution
is not just the Constitution that is
effective the US Constitution is given
content by you know all the judgments of
the Supreme Court the famous judgments
of the Supreme Court is what makes the
Constitution what it is today so is not
clear that you can just transplant the
Constitution without the history that
goes with it so that says that if you
believe this point of view you could you
should be very pessimistic because it's
not actually saying that you know we
just have to fake good institutions this
is where I think easterly is wrong isn't
the development policy is even if you
believe this point of view it doesn't
say much our development policy because
it actually doesn't tell you that you
can fix institutions today in Mali and
you'll get good outcomes so and as above
our mobility is an Jeong and Robinson
are very consistent in their book they
basically explicitly state this
pessimistic position they say we God
knows how to fix countries let's not
even bother most of it as their position
and that's a very entirely consistent
position now the other people who take a
less consistent position who want to say
that your institution important this is
the evidence from are similar and
Robinson and now we're going to go fix
countries which is a very different
claim that we're going to fix
institutions this is evidence doesn't
say that you can fix institutions it
says if you had the right institutions
400 years ago then it would be good
that's very different from saying we can
fix institutions do you see that yeah
we
me but not tomorrow not tomorrow so we
did I have nothing useful to say over
400 years from now but the Recon can't
but it doesn't say what it clearly
doesn't say is if I fix the institution
thing will be better today that's what
that it does not say yeah
right so that's also true that you know
I think the point you're making is also
important which is that and we don't
know how to village it's not that we can
go on you know it's not that in other
words people don't leave in a body the
immunity of our country which doesn't
have so here's a fact that I always in
mine good way almost any country take a
taxi click exception but they take it
back safe i'm in many countries get off
of a taxi is a real either agreed or an
amount when you got on the Texas or you
good what is a meter you read the meter
you give the person the amount come over
and at that point the person you know
person takes the money he shuts them
meter off and he says here's your change
this happens in many many countries now
what's remarkable about I said not the
world is that well why did I patient I
could have said look you know
so what if it says 20 I'm going to give
you five and what's to stop me there's
nobody else who's there when usually I
get up in front of a house there's no
one else there I can walk off by the
time he's a taxi driver and find the
policeman i'll be gone on one side so i
must be so the response has to be that
I'm afraid of the taxi driver BTW mia
which may be true but if the taxi driver
can beat me up why isn't the reverse
true why isn't a taxi driver as soon as
I guess the taxi stop why doesn't it
send to beat me up and say that you have
to be 40 instead of 20 or I'll beat you
up and claim that you didn't pay for you
or me 40 how is it that we managed to
negotiate this space in many many
countries successful me if the taxi
driver if I'm paying that accident visit
Xavier can beat me up then he should
beat me up in any case and if it is if
we if he is paying me because if I'm
paying him and otherwise we can't beat
me up then I shouldn't pay him in any
case so why do I pay him and why does
these transactions thousands of millions
of these transactions always happen so
it must be that even societies that
don't have good property right
institutions and forceful up top have
figured out ways to enforce lots of
contracts on the ground that has to be
true that we a lot of the what we call
property rights must live in other forms
then the form that we think of as the
official form yeah you had a comment
absolutely it's a trust or something
like that is important the only point
I'm making here that's not a property
right that's something else that is
important so there lots of substitute
here
Oh
think of it as a game over and over then
yeah I don't want to play with the same
taxi driver so next I'm gonna cheat the
next extra day but you know that's that
that's a bad outcome that is the outcome
predicted by the game that there will be
no taxes in fact taxes exist because we
have trust we have norms way of all
kinds of things we live outside this
institutional frame so one point that I
think is important is to think of you
know if you want to transplant
institutions you have to realize that
institutions already exist in this
country's even the ones which you think
don't have institutions have tons and
tons of them and you are always you know
trying to turn existing institutions or
other institutions you are not creating
institutions de novo anywhere ever so
we'll pick that up next time